je comprends très bien l'objectif de la
mesure l'objectif de la mesure ce décret
redémarrer quand on voit de près
redémarrer s'assurer aussi que nos
entreprises traitent et g on avait parlé
beaucoup dans les derniers mois entre
autres toutes les technologies de
l'information où on avait une pénurie
d'employés donc je peux comprendre
certaines entreprises d'être un peu
stressée à l'idée de perdre leurs gains
d'emplois avec des gens par exemple du
secteur des technologies d'information
avec nous ce soir françois vincent vice
président de la fédération canadienne de
l'entreprise indépendante au québec
reçoivent un savon soir bonsoir
subventionné 100 % des salaires vous en
pensez quoi de cette proposition de
monsieur gaudin nous on demande la
subvention salariale depuis quelques
jours notre proposition c'est 75% du
salaire jusqu'à concurrence de 5000 $
travailleurs pour un mois
on pense que c'est une bonne idée et
pour toutes les entreprises pas juste
les entreprises stratégiques parce
qu'actuellement les pme sont frappés de
plein fouet par là et économique
actuellement et c'est une des bonnes
manières de pouvoir leur permettre de
garder leurs employés clés et d'être
présidente
lorsqu'on va voir passer à travers cette
tempête pourquoi ça c'est une bonne
manière pour quoi vous pensez que cette
formule-là de subventionner une partie
ou la totalité des salaires et une
meilleure façon que les autres mesures
qui existent l'égard des liens avec l'un
avec les employés actuellement là on a
fait un sondage qu'on ait dévoilé ce
matin 25 % des pme qui ont dû remercier
la totalité dollars aux employés
quand elles vont reprendre ça va être
beaucoup plus complexe d'aller chercher
ces personnes là donc avec la subvention
salariale ça permet justement d'aider
l'entreprise
un autre élément c'est que les charges
salariales pour les petites et moyennes
entreprises sont là le point le plus
important donc avec une subvention
salariale on leur permet de rester sur
le respirateur artificiel pendant cette
période trouble puis ensuite de toutes
les pme qui représentent le poumon
économique du québec pour une présente
pour partir dès le
jour un pattern trois quatre cinq jours
puis en vrai dans la paperasse pour
trouver des nouveaux employés et donc un
besoin du gouvernement du canada offre
une subvention salariale de 10% du
salaire jusqu'à concurrence de 1000 375
$ par employé
25000 par employeur est ce que vous
jugez que c'est totalement insuffisant
mais la semaine passée c'était bon mais
ça escalade tellement rapidement et vous
lui faisiez à tous les jours aussi
regardant les nouvelles économiques
quelle est sa ça fonctionne plus c'est
bien mais maintenant il faut des mesures
plus musclées plus agressifs pour
protéger les pme
ils ont dit dans notre sondage le tiers
sont pas capables de passer un mois dans
la situation actuelle il ya une semaine
c'était le quart et le tiers des pme au
québec c'est beaucoup c'est un impact
important dans l'ensemble des régions du
québec
donc oui c'est bien la semaine passée
mais maintenant il faut agir plus
fortement plus directement et en même
temps protéger des vies puis faire le
maximum pour le faire j'invite toute la
population et toutes les entreprises à
suivre les indications du gouvernement
du québec
mais en même temps il faut avoir la même
énergie pour soutenir notre économie
soutenir nos pme pour passer à travers
parce que c'est ça l'enjeu aussi la
fermeture des entreprises jugées non
essentielles qui a été annoncé par le
premier ministre legault hier à 13
heures la liste des entreprises jugées
essentielles est sorti à 17 heures donc
il ya eu un flou cette liste est ajusté
entre temps il n'y a pas de mesure
particulière qui ont été annoncés en
même temps que la fermeture des
entreprises jugées non essentielles et
cette fermeture c'est ce soir est ce que
vous trouvez que le soutien dans cette
opération est suffisante
il s'en prend plus la fédération
canadienne de l'entreprise indépendante
on est en contact avec l'ensemble des
gouvernements ainsi que de la
sensibilité aux cycles les choses vont
s'en venait maintenant faut pas attendre
trop longtemps parce que le propriétaire
de la pme look perdu tout son marché que
pas de vendre mais lui là c'est une
question de d'or une question de jours
pour prendre ses décisions
donc on a vraiment besoin d'un message
des instances gouvernantes
mental pour aider justement les
entrepreneurs qui font face à cette
crise l'actuellement québec offre des
presses ledit de 50000 $ et plus
investissement québec il ya des gens qui
nous disent qu'ils nous écrivent moi
j'ai besoin de vingt mille ou trente
mille mais je me qualifie pas pour ça
est ce que vous pensez que on devrait
élargir ce programme là ça prend
différentes mesures pour répondre à
différentes situations là ce programme
là est bien mais maintenant pour des
plus petits entrepreneurs il s'est pas
nécessairement après qu'on va pouvoir
les aider plus parce qu'après sur leur
ratio d'endettement vont peut-être trop
important quand on va sortir de cette
période là nos données nous démontrer
que les petites entreprises elles quand
elles vont avoir besoin de refinancement
c'est leur marge de crédit personnelle
c'est la carte de crédit donc c'est pas
nécessairement avec des prêts
supplémentaires qu'on va les aider
d'où l'importance de la subvention
salariale puis en même temps aussi leur
donner des liquidités en leur donnant
une pause pour pocket de remise de tps
un autre exemple les taxes municipales
ce ne sont pas toutes les municipalités
encore qui ont annoncé une pause ou le
loyer je dirigeais plein pme qui n'ont
pas accès à leur local mais qui doivent
encore payer un loyer
donc ce sont des mesures un bouquet de
mesures qu'on doit mettre en place
rapidement pour les aider à passer à
travers
le président des états unis a lancé tout
un débat sur la relance plus rapide de
l'économie deux semaines trois semaines
je sais que ça se parle au g20 on en
parlait hier avec l'économiste clément
gignac vous est ce que vous êtes d'avis
qu'il va falloir relancer à si
rapidement l'économie
[Musique]
nous on est d'avis qu'il faut aider les
entreprises maintenant là c'est une
question de jour le jour il faut que les
entrepreneurs soient au courant de
qu'est-ce qu'on peut les aider
comment on peut les aider notamment avec
la subvention salariale oui vous pensez
à la reprise mais là faut penser et je
pense au jour le jour ça évolue
tellement rapidement
oui monsieur vincent fermé l'économie
comme on le fait deux trois semaines
c'est une chose mais si on le faisait
encore un autre trois semaines loeb
conserve jusqu'au mois de mai est ce
qu'on est capable de faire ça est ce
qu'on doit faire c'est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça il faut sauver des vies
il faut en aucun cas on regarde ce qui
se passe ailleurs si on compte 6 1 paul
d
les russes savoir avoir un impact
important puis pas juste sur des
personnes âgées sur l'ensemble de la
population
maintenant quand on regarde aussi en
asie comment ça reprend en chine il
commença donc je crois qu'il faut mettre
en place des mesures économiques faut
pas en avoir peur non plus d'être trop
pris auprès de notre portefeuille the
fall en déficit budgétaire à l'urgente
économique qu'il faut adopter pour les
pma passe à travers puis et pour en
venir la situation au niveau de
l'économie
merci beaucoup monsieur vincent pour cet
entretien merci